The Joe Rogan experience.
Well,
it's fascinating to me that the geneticists would rely on the archeologists
being that the geneticists have the actual DNA.
They can examine where the archeologists are piecing things together.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Tiny bits of information over the entire landscape.
And then you consider how much information they don't have access to that's in
the ground.
Exactly.
I strongly resist the idea that archeology is a science.
I,
I don't think it should be described as a science.
What do you think it should be described as?
It's more like a kind of philosophy.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an attempt to interpret the past based on rather flimsy and limited
evidence.
And what you find in that interpretation is that the preconceptions of the
individuals involved are being imposed upon the evidence,
which then turns out to support their preconceptions.
And that's not a scientific way of doing things.
Assigned to any way of doing things is testing,
testing hypotheses and false seeking to falsify them and seeing if they,
if they,
if they work out.
So the problem is drawing these conclusions and then being too rigid with these
conclusions.
That's on further evidence.
That's,
that's my view.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that um,
archeology has been,
has been much too rigid and,
and the,
and that there's a,
there's a climate of fear in archeology.
I don't mean to pick particularly on archeologists here.
I think this is generally true across other disciplines as well.
Um,
these days academics are driven by the need to publish research papers.
That's what they build their careers on.
If they can get a paper on their bit of research published in nature of the
proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
et Cetera,
that's good for their careers.
But then you confront the gatekeepers in those publications who regard any
archeological idea that is not part of the mainstream accepted consensus with
great suspicion and are most most reluctant,
uh,
to,
you know,
to publish,
to publish that information.
Now,
what is the mainstream,
what,
when,
when archeologists talk about seafaring humans,
what do they date that too?
Well,
there's the Great Asians.
Yes,
the great seafaring adventure that is accepted by archeology is called the
Polynesian expansion.
And it's a remarkable story.
And that occurs roughly 3000 to 3,500 years ago.
And those Polynesians were amazing ocean navigators.
They could,
they could cross distances of thousands of kilometers with pinpoint accuracy.
I mean,
it's not an accident that the Polynesians found Easter island fighting Easter
island is a really challenging project.
Easter island is 2000 miles from the coast of South America.
It's 2000 miles from the nearest other island,
which is Tahiti.
It's just a little speck in the middle of the ocean.
But the Polynesians founded and settled there and appear to have brought a
reproductively viable population there and appear to have made voyages back and
forth.
But that was 3000 to 3,500 years ago.
That was not 12,800 years ago.
Uh,
and this is,
this is where archeology is adamant position that ocean voyaging was begun by
the Polynesians and that there was no major ocean voyages before.
That I think needs to be strongly questioned and it needs to be strongly
questioned in the light of this DNA evidence from the Amazon rather than
rejecting the evidence and attempt should be made to consider what that might
mean.
Well,
it's interesting because we know that the Egyptians had boats.
Yeah.
And so what I mean,
if there were boats 4,000,
500 years ago,
why do we think that they didn't try them out in the ocean?
That doesn't make any sense.
Especially if there exists a thousand years prior,
which is also possible.
Archeologist wouldn't argue that the Egyptians had boats,
but,
but that is,
that is still within the,
the framework of accepted history.
It's,
it's the notion of a,
of a global navigating culture in the ice age that archeologists can't swallow.
It's a subject that I've kept on coming up against over a number of years.
I think the best evidence for it is ancient maps,
uh,
which show the world as it looked during the last ice age.
I've first explored this in fingerprints of the gods and I've touched on the
mystery again and I haven't it an appendix on the subject in,
in,
in this book because I think these are very important.
We're talking about maps that were drawn roughly between the 13 hundreds and the
17 hundreds.
Uh,
in other words,
in relatively recent history,
however,
these maps were largely based on much older source maps,
which they copied.
And we can say that for sure because one of the famous maps is the period Reese
map,
which was created by a Turkish admiral called Perry Reece in the year 15,
13.
Uh,
actually only a corner of his map has survived.
It was originally a world map.
We now just have a bit that shows the east coast of South America and North
America and the west coast of Africa,
Perry Reece rights in that map that it is in his own handwriting that he based
it on more than 100 older source maps,
some of which had come from the library of Alexandria.
In other words,
that maps had been when the library of Alexandria had been destroyed in the
fourth century D or whenever it was.
Some of its contents had been rescued and brought to Constantinople which became
the Turkish capitol and Perry Reece had access to those maps and he incorporated
information from those maps on his maps as well as incorporating more recent
navigational information and this is one of a whole category of maps which are
extremely hard to explain.
All of them based on older source maps now lost all of them incorporating
extremely precise relative longitudes and latitudes.
Latitude is not that difficult to technological feat,
but longer chewed is a difficult technological feat.
Longitude involves a chronometer.
It involves knowing the time at the place you began,
your voyage and the local and local noon as well.
And calculating the difference between them.
You need a chronometer that we'll keep accurate time at sea with the Mo motions
of a ship.
And it's just a plain fact that our civilization did not invent such a
chronometer until the late 18th century.
Before that we know what longitude where we were at and ships were constantly
sailing unexpectedly into coastlines that they thought were hundreds of miles
further away.
So the discovery of the technique to do longer chewed was a major civilizational
advance.
Its presence in maps based on much older source maps that actually show the
world as it looks during the last ice age suggests that somebody during the last
ice age was mapping the world and had mastered the technique of calculating a
longitude.
Classic example of these maps,
um,
and I make a point at this is what's called the Pinkerton world map,
which was drawn in the year 1818 and it was based on the latest navigational
information at that time.
I reproduced that map in the,
in the book.
What's missing from the map entirely missing is Antarctica.
There's just a hole at the bottom of the world.
There's nothing there.
And the reason,
the reason,
there's nothing there,
there's another,
there's another pink than map that,
uh,
that shows that,
um,
the,
the reason that you need to find one that's centered on Antarctica,
the reason,
the reason that Antarctica is not there is that our civilization hadn't
discovered Antarctica in 1818 so they couldn't authentically put it on a map in
1818 actually,
we discovered it in 1819 and that's when it starts appearing on modern maps.
The problem is that Antarctica repeat appears repeatedly on these much older
maps and it appears in the right place and a bit bigger than it is today,
but very much as it looked during the last ice age.
So what all of this suggests to me is that the world was mapped and explored by
a global seafaring culture with the level of technology that was at least
equivalent to ours at the end of the 18th century.
Uh,
during the ice age.
Wasn't there also a map of Greenland that showed it underneath the ice?
Yes,
there are.
And,
and,
and uh,
another intriguing thing I met,
I mentioned the period Reece map just now shown on the period Reese map lying
off the east coast of North America is a large island with a row of megaliths,
like a road of megaliths running up the middle of it.
Um,
that island is in the exact place of the Grand Bahama banks.
Uh,
and,
and the last one.
Yeah,
it is.
Um,
but can I point it out to you because we're not sure.
That's right.
Okay.
The thing that one,
okay,
that's great that you can bring this up Jeremy.
That's amazing.
So this island is sitting there off the southeast coast of North America where
these to draw things back then too.
And what you see running down the middle of it is this road like feature of a
mega list c right there.
Yeah.
Now,
the thing is,
it was a long period of my life when I,
I did a lot of scuba diving and I was looking at at underwater structures and
one of the sites had typed on was the Bimini road,
which is in the Grand Bahama banks and the [inaudible] road is exactly where the
island is and the that,
here's the issue.
I don't care whether the Bimini road is natural or manmade.
For me the mystery is that it is shown above water on that map.
And the last time it was above water was thousands and thousands of years ago.
So for me this is all evidence that we shouldn't dismiss the possibility that
our ancestors had achieved a level of technology where they could explore in
that the world's oceans.
We shouldn't dismiss that.
There it is.
We don't know what those stones are,
how they were created by bully.
Do they look artifacts you on a Goonie in Japan.
We're looking at now,
but the go back to that image and did the last image that we were just looking
at.
Look at that.
I mean that looks so [inaudible] and you can see that is rather than like the,
the,
the pattern that's showing on the,
on the island in the,
in the map,
how deep is that today?
Oh,
it's not very deep.
It's about 20 feet then.
But we think that that was above water at some point with Steve was definitely
above water during the last ice age when it,
when it finally went underwater.
May have been as late as eight or 9,000 years ago.
Is there anything else compelling that's in the immediate area that seems to
indicate that there was some sort of a manmade structure?
Well,
nobody's looked for it.
Uh,
and the whole effort of archeology has been to dismiss the significance of the
bib.
Any road.
How would they dismiss that?
Well,
they say it's just a me,
they say it's totally Natural Karma is it?
Let's go.
Go back to that image again.
Some other ones listen,
but,
but well this is the odd,
could go back to that image that we just saw.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Somebody who spent a lot of time diving on the Bimini road.
I can tell you I absolutely do not think it's natural.
I think it's a manmade structure,
but the argument is that it's a kind of beach rock that forms in these blocky
formation is that speech rock does for in Bucky permission,
but here I believe that the beach rock has been used as a construction material,
but I repeat,
the key issue is not whether the Bimini road is my made or not.
The key issue is that it features on a map above water and that is a dating
project that tells us that somebody was mapping that bit of the world when it
was above water and that takes us back a very long,
a long way into the past.
The the one that you just pulled up.
Yeah,
look at that one.
That's a stunning place,
isn't it mate?
It's amazing site.
It's just like the odds of that being in that order with those uniformly sized
rocks first.
How long is that?
Oh,
hundreds of feet.
It's not a huge,
it's actually shaped like the letter j.
It's a giant underwater structure is really,
really an enormous thing and very,
very beautiful dive on.
And there's lots of very gentle,
sweet nurse sharks down there that you can play with this.
So that looks much more like random.
That's more random and bits of it,
bits of it do look more random.
Bits of it look highly constructed.
I would not,
um,
I would not seek to,
to claim that the Bimini road is absolutely manmade.
My claim about the Bimini road is it's really fucking weird that it appears on a
map above water,
a map that was drawn in 15,
13 based on older source maps.